yeah they're good people you know New
Yorkers are great yeah they really they
might be cold when you first meet them
but they have to be when you're meeting
a million people yeah that's exactly
what it is but I tell you what so I've
salted the Earth you know
um that I've I know personally your New
Yorkers are solid yeah
so Nils knows you grew up where I was
born in Brooklyn New York and um I was
in Brooklyn until I was five years old
and my dad who was a New York City
firefighter decided to get out to the
Suburban part of the city which was
Staten Island
um spent pretty much my childhood in
except for my sophomore year of high
school I lived in Ireland my mom is an
Irish immigrant some first generation
American very grateful
um my father had gone through a very bad
cancer in 1978 he was diagnosed with
end-stage Non-Hodgkin's lymphoma
and was more or less sent home to die
and one of the doctors approached them
and said we'd like you to be a test
pilot for this new drug we're working on
and he said I'm not a pilot I'm a
fireman in this you know Brooklyn accent
and they explained to him no we you're
going to die anyway so why don't you
give this a try
and uh my dad did he uh he went through
chemo every two weeks for four years and
it was brutal it was a vicious strong
drug
and it uh saved his life he's still in
remission and he's turning 84 tomorrow
yeah so uh my dad is my uh inspiration
and uh I have a tattoo on my arm it says
my example my hero my father
with his badge that I eventually took
over on a fire department so uh
it's a good man he he filled my soul
with goodness and benevolence he just
always does the right thing and uh my
Irish mother
same same sort of hers and just
assaulted the Earth doing anything for
you but what had happened is once my
father was in remission he had enough
years to retire
and my mom's fear was that he would
succumb to the cancer eventually so her
safety net was back in Ireland
um there was she was one of ten children
and at that point they all had kids and
my my grandmother had just passed so we
decided my parents decided I didn't want
to really do it they packed it in and we
moved to Ireland
and uh back in the early 80s it was bad
times economically there and my father
couldn't find work and his pension
wouldn't be enough to sustain
you know us as a family
so uh
my Dad decided after just short of a
year we were coming back but I had a
great experience there
um went to a small uh school out in a
rural Irish Town run by the Christian
Brothers which I was familiar with
because I have attended Catholic High
School here
and one of my uh my favorite I guess
stories was uh there was only about 12
or 13 of us in each grade
and they had put me back agreed because
they start much younger there and their
curriculum is different
so one of my classmates Mike Hennessey
who I remember was a smaller guy and
adopted me as his bodyguard so Mike uh
unfortunately would puff up standing
behind me and pick fights with the
upperclassmen
so uh it started to get a little old
because I wasn't getting paid but Mike
one day picked it and I ended up in a
fight with
about 12 guys from junior year
and I'm fighting for my life just
throwing Haymakers and I'm not much of a
fighter I'm you know was bullied quite a
bit as a younger kid and I despise
bullies
but I was in a fight for my life and as
I looked over one of the Christian
Brothers who was this towering old
Irishman with white hair he's just
standing there was arms folded staring
at me and I'm looking his name is
brother O'Keefe and I'm like brother any
minute now please bail me out I need a
lifeline and all of a sudden he just
finally came over and broke it up and he
pulled me to the side and he says Jesus
I thought I was watching The Quiet Man
himself which was the old John Wayne
movie fighting all these Irish men he
says you were doing great yank and I
said brother you I was getting pummeled
he said I know I just wanted to see what
you had you did just fine you'll be
grand and I kind of I guess uh made my
bones with those guys they respected the
fact that I didn't cave into him but uh
I took a good beating and uh came back
to America
uh back to my old high school
unfortunately fell behind
failed out so I ended up in public high
school down the road to finish up so I
didn't really get to graduate with my
classmates which was a little tough for
me you know I didn't really make a bond
with within one year of being in the
other school but I held my own
came back to uh play baseball which was
my love at the time
uh played quite a bit of little league
and Babe Ruth ball
and I came home to find out that one of
my best friends from my team was in the
process of dying from leukemia
and it was heartbreaking because I had
moved away not knowing it and came home
and it was too late it was too late to
see him he was in hospice and um
you know it it really hit me it affected
me I guess in a great way because
my father was always on that cusp of
dying for quite a while and my
grandfather who was my my best friend in
the world uh on his namesake and
I kind of didn't like my name as a kid
you know Nails was a little different
and odd compared to most people but now
I kind of love it because it's it's
Unique and different like me
um but Grandpa Nils had died and now my
father was in the process of maybe dying
and now I lost a dear friend and
that's kind of I guess grabbed a hold of
me that's really never let go since
um I've always had a huge uh
respect for it I guess you can say or
maybe maybe it's an intimidation thing
uh
feared it but not to a point that I
couldn't live and function but it's
always kind of in the back of my mind
and and there was a lot of death there
was a lot of close relatives and
neighbors and friends and it just seemed
like it just never really receded
but life moved on pretty good I love
baseball but I knew from probably you
know five years old I wanted to be a
fireman like my father
uh you know we used to grow up with
Heroes and I'm not sure how many heroes
are left you know legitimate Heroes uh
people that inspire you to be a better
person better human being better man
and my father did that and I remember
witnessing at such a young age what he
did it was it was powerful
you know uh my mom would bring us by the
firehouse once in a while to bring him a
little snack you know we we cook in the
firehouse we live there we eat there but
we just go to see him I remember just
walking in seeing these Giants with
mustaches and you know like fuss over
here and they put you on the truck and
you put on a helmet and a coat and
you're walking around thinking man yeah
you know five years old I could I could
do this
you know they're feeding your ice cream
cake and cookies and just like
it was just like going to a party and uh
the smell in the firehouse of the truck
and and the diesel and the tires and the
Smoky gear because you know back
back in the 70s I mean they were busy
there was a lot of fires in New York
City there was a lot of
social reasons uh unrest there was a
program where people would burn
themselves out to get a new house
so anytime I went to that Firehouse just
you know your older Factory sense is so
strong and I just I don't know it just
just triggered something and then when
we lived in Bay Ridge till I was five
there was a firehouse right on the
corner and
so I used to sit on that corner with my
little big wheel my mom would be out in
her beach chair talking with the
neighbors and and I've just been waiting
for these guys to come out and
occasionally my dad's truck would get
pulled down there so if there was a fire
in that District they call it a
relocation they'll pull other fire
companies from various areas to kind of
backfill
so you know one day I'm there and here
comes my dad down on the truck and I'm
like holy you know does my dad I'm
racing up to see him
so I'd sit at that corner and then when
they would come out on calls I just
raced down alongside of them for a good
20 feet maybe laughing and then they
were gone uh so yeah I just got hooked
got hooked at a young age uh with that
whole world and
you know they were good Role Models they
I remember my dad's you know buddies
they carpool to Staten Island and you
know they they come by the house for
coffee after a long through the night
shift and sit and just talk about what
happened at night and hear the stories
and you know one of my dad's friends Mr
Moran he was just such an animated
characters Airborne Ranger in Korea and
you know just I just felt like I was
sitting amongst giants like just looking
up hearing these stories
um
so that was my dream I was focused on it
um I had a chance actually to try out
for Major League Baseball
um I was I was a pitcher center field
their first baseman
and I threw pitch really fast but really
wild like a Mustang and uh unfortunately
could never really harness that so my
skill set wasn't uh enough to make it to
the majors
so I settled for uh
joining the Army and then down the road
uh joining the New York City Police
Department
knowing that I was just waiting out on a
list to get on the fire department
um my father had had motivated me to
take all the Civil Service tests that
were available in the city
so I was kind of Trapped in a world of
heavy manual construction demolition uh
really I'm glad I did it but it was it
was a tough tough job uh got laid off
from that during the economic crisis I
guess in the 80s and I worked in a
nursing home as an orderly on midnights
uh cleaning and tending to elderly male
patients that were bedridden and it was
uh it was humbling it was really
humbling
because you realize that you know we're
fragile we think we're in control we're
independent and you know on both sides
of life and infancy and in the elderly
years you're you're you need other
people to take care of you
so I I kind of took it as a high honor
to attend to these older men
um
because many of them World War II
veterans and some from Korea
and they all wanted to teach you
their their lessons in life or reinforce
their failures and and ask you as a
young as I was 18 at the time 19 to not
make the mistakes they made
and
I learned to listen uh at times in life
that kind of wavered I you know whenever
you just get caught up in your own being
but at that point in time really learn
to listen
and some of the stories were fascinating
you know I I had one gentleman that was
a one of the first motorcycle police
officers in New York City and he
probably had pictures of himself back in
like the late 20s on a motorcycle and it
was just incredible you know to say wow
here's this 85 year old man or 90 year
old man but they had a life and they had
a story and they they wanted to tell it
to anyone who would listen
so that really made a big impact that
wasn't a job I held for a long time
I've had many jobs
I have to say the best job I've ever had
which I still actually have is being a
father being a dad I have three
beautiful uh
sorry just
I I I never thought I'd live to see them
grow and prosper into these beautiful
adults that they are these contributors
to this world
and I've held multiple jobs and many of
them brought me such satisfaction such
Joy I I was joyous to get on a fire
truck to help people
but uh
that
the joy of of being a father
uh surpasses anything in this world you
know and I and I think it's actually a a
Salient problem in in the society or in
worldwide
um there's a lack of fathers you know
you when you when you take it upon
yourself to
to have this child with with a woman and
not follow through
um not take the full responsibility of
the nurturing and development and
guidance of that little human being in
this crazy world
you're doing everybody a disservice and
uh
you know I've come across people in my
own life that that have been abandoned
um by their dads at Birth young age
and their life's been so tormented
because of that because they had so many
doubts about themselves they couldn't
understand was it them were they not
worthy of his love or you know the why
the why tormented them
and I get really aggravated at people
just throwing all these excuses around
and you know I've been told I have
privilege and I get a little bit upset
because I say you're right I do
I'm privileged to have two parents who
loved me who sacrificed everything of
themselves for the betterment of myself
and my brother and my sister
and my wife and I committed to that same
track when we had our our children we
have three children and she left her
career and I took it upon myself to
always have two a lot of times three
jobs to keep her home raising them uh to
try to put them in a little better of a
school because the school district we
were in was was a little dicey and I
didn't want them getting bullied like I
did and harassed and beat up
and
there was days when I felt like wow do I
ever do anything for myself or my wife
like is it just all about the kids
and the reality is yeah until they're
adults and you can get them on their own
it's all about the kids
so you know I like to opine about a lot
of things
um personally I hate politics I think
politicians are all liars
so I'm I'm a independent I'm a free
thinker
and to me you could solve so many of the
societal ills by trying to bring back a
family structure you know I I asked my
mom and my dad I said what do I do you
know when I had my first daughter was
overwhelming with this little soul and
I'm like bring it bringing her home and
crying she needs to eat I'm like holy
shoot what do I do and my mom my Irish
mother said they don't come with a
manual you know you just you just love
them and you figure it out and and it's
true
and you know I
just took public transportation to get
over here we're in the middle of New
York City
and it's sad as a father to see so many
young broken Souls that are lining the
sidewalks and today is you know
impressively hot it's it's 100 degrees
I've been to fires that weren't quite as
hot I mean you know you ride the subway
in New York City with 100 degrees you
feel like you just entered into the
confines of hell
but I look at these broken souls and
they're laying there and they're
listless and they're begging and they're
hooked on drugs and they're 19. they've
given up already and they really haven't
even lived life they're still babies you
know when you're 19 you're a baby
and you know I was out in Denver a
little while back visiting someone and
uh you know buddy of mine we decided to
take in a baseball game and you know
walking downtown or walking to the
stadium
and there was just this Litany of
fractured Souls everywhere young people
just with tents and shanties and signs
and you know they were begging and if
you didn't give them money they were
cursing you out and I'm going
you're 19. how are you so jaded and
broken and angry at this point in life
you haven't even experienced it and then
I stopped and I realized that I said
they they probably have a broken life
they don't have anyone who loves them
and guides them
and and you know I'm not going to say
that every person that's loved and
guided will not fall down and and hurt
themselves by their activities but
you know what my parents taught me and I
taught my my kids is every action causes
a reaction
every action that you commit comes with
a response it's either going to be a
reward for your hard work and you're
you're being a good person or a
consequence and sometimes that
consequence is severe it'll cause you
addiction it'll cause you incarceration
it will cause you getting killed
overdose dead in a car accident and it's
it's really simple it's just like when
we used to have road maps right you know
we go where am I going no not on the
phone you know you got to look at a map
and you had to guide your course and go
oh crap okay that's where I'm going
and you know I I think we're just taking
down all of the uh
the guides you know like when I was a
kid my dad liked bowling and you know we
didn't really go a lot because he was
always working and he was sick but the
few times he took us
when we were little they put up the
barriers on the side of the lane because
you know you're little and you're just
gonna throw the ball and it's gonna go
in the gutter so that barrier prevented
you from ending up in the gutter and you
hit some pins
but then as you got a little older if
you really want to learn how to bowl you
got to take the barriers down you got to
learn how to keep the ball in the middle
it's kind of like life you know if we
keep these barriers up for young people
from old people of any age and just keep
letting them repeat their mistakes with
no consequences you know I'm not saying
that somebody you know who who gets
hooked on something or whatever you know
needs to be put in jail for life or
whatever but we can't keep rewarding
mediocrity or listlessness or just not
giving a right like like how do you
reward that and and you know I see
sometimes even my kids they're they're
really hard working they they study they
train that you know what they're all
guarantored in life
and now it's being held against them
they're being told that though it was
easy for them and you know they went to
a better school and they their parents
paid for it or this and it's like no
bull crap you know you could go to the
best school in the world and still be an
F up if you don't apply yourself right
and and that's what just really tweaks
me is that so many people now are are
making excuses for failure and
do believe in Redemption I believe in
second chances there are chances but
after a while it just it just starts to
get old you know
um
yeah so so uh I'm sorry I'm just kind of
yeah I think it's what you just said a
few minutes ago
you loved your kids I love them they're
my life
and because you loved your kids they
know that they're worthy of love
so they have loving themselves they
learn how to love themselves yes yeah
you're right Mark they did and they love
others these kids are these people that
you're talking about that are on the
streets or involved in drugs or whatever
it is
they never had that yeah and they're so
worthy of the parent bailed and was that
the messages that you're not worthy of
us yes and you can't love yourself and
there you go and their self-worth then
is just crushed and and they go through
life with that seed of doubt in your
head forever
yeah and I think I think that's really
one of the common denominators of of
I feel like our country's failing in a
lot of ways right
um
you know all the technology and
advancements
that we have it's it's like
life seems to be receding in quality
you know they they talk about like a
misery Factor right and you know I'm
going to be 55 years older
few couple months and
I just feel like I've never seen such a
level of unhappiness and
jadedness and
almost people are just like different
disenfranchised and they've been you
know
I don't know how to explain it like that
just the Soul's been pulled out of them
and they've just given up you know and
look I understand you know faith is is a
is a very
touchy subject right today's Times
um I happen to have a very strong faith
um but I don't Infuse it on other people
if they ask me about it I'll really tell
them and why I believe and you know what
have you but I would never impose that
on someone else you know I'm I'm I guess
very libertarian in my life I feel like
look it's your life this is mine don't
force me to do or believe in what you do
and I won't do it to you
but the one thing I think that a common
uh
I guess you can say
you know ingredient of Life Is Love I
don't care where you live in the world
your culture your background is
everybody except for a complete
sociopath wants to be loved and cared
about they want to feel like they matter
and I you know I'm not going to say
every person that I've come across is
going to like me right I'm an
opinionated guy I was a boss in the fire
department a lieutenant not not a chief
failed accountants test twice
but I remember
Captain I used to drive
love them one of my mentors my
inspirations
John McGuire I used to drive him in 114
and he used to say to me we called him
the Duke he just had an elegant way of
of carrying himself and and like he was
a good boss a firm boss
not hard but fair but but you knew what
he wanted it was no BS and he said to me
this he said when you make it to boss he
goes
if the don't like you I mean
you're doing your job and you're doing
it well so I'm not going to lie to you
and say every first responder that I
work with I was Ems for a very short
time NYPD for almost two years
New York City Fire for almost 22.
not every single responder I work with
was was the greatest human being in the
world but
99 of them are
they went to work
where they were willing to give up their
life for me
for you any stranger that you just saw
out in the street
that's pretty profound you know a friend
of mine's a corporate guy he just said
it to me recently he said you know I've
dedicated my life to
to to a job where I don't think there's
one person in my office or my firm that
would say I'll die for you today well
every single person I work with
felt that way with me and and me with
them
so I took that as a very very high honor
and responsibility but when it came to
being a boss you know
if
someone was harassing another guy for a
certain reason you know you know it was
just things that happened I didn't let
it stand
um I was bullied bad as a kid right
because I was it was always a pretty big
kid now I'm a little too big but
I got bullied really badly and it was it
was in the height of my father being so
sick so emotionally I was I was in a bad
place and my granddad died and I you
know I thought the war was ending and
then I had this one guy every day I get
off the school bus and boom he punched
me in the stomach it's like just to
humiliate me and make me cry in front of
30 other kids
and that happened every day and that
sucked and when I started to get older
and bigger
my father at one point said look you
know you're going to need to start
working out and do a little boxing
because I had this one neighborhood
bully I'll never forget it he was three
years older than me
pick the fight with me I got him into a
headlock and I said okay Frankie you
know you're trying to prove your point
let's just let this go because my father
always says it takes a man to walk away
from a fight
so I was so proud to to know I could
have just pummeled the piss out of this
guy but I let him go well he came
running back around
four shots to my nose I was done and I
went home crying and I said to my dad
but Dad you told me it takes a man to
walk away from a fight
and I was 12 and I was crushed and he
said no no you misunderstood me he said
I don't want you looking for fights but
you have to defend yourself now let me
teach you how
so once I started on that path I I took
it upon myself to sort of be the
anti-bully well God made me big for a
reason I'm going to put my bigness in
the way of bad and Evil
and there's one incident that kind of
haunts me still because I didn't know
how to handle it and I was
16 and I was in football camp
and I was the new guy on the team
and we were up in this these cabins
Upstate and
one of the kids in my cabin was a
freshman for my neighborhood just a real
character really nice nice kid he
reminded me of uh the catcher from
Sandlot that kid uh almost screaming at
Smalls I forget his name he had that
chubby look and
and I remember one night
a bunch of the seniors the big the big
dudes the jocks the starters they came
in and these like weird alfreds and they
started pummeling this kid
and they pushed them down and they
violated them they they
took this stick and they put it in his
rectum and made him cry and did it you
know until they stopped laughing they
did it for maybe 30 seconds a minute
and I sat there horrified and I felt
like a coward because
there was 12 of them and it was me and
finally I just snapped and I said you
know you guys are guys are
you're cowards what the frick are you
doing what are you doing to this kid
sick bastards and then they got pissed
and they whoa that's you and they
stormed down
well the next day I practice now I'm the
tackling dummy right I got all these big
dudes now they're gonna tackle the
out of me and not even tackle but hit
and Spear and crush me and you know
try to send a message
but I had asked the kid I said you want
me to tell the coach you want me to tell
someone and he cried please no no I
please don't if if you do I'll be marked
I'll be I'll be done
and I listen to him
and I didn't go forward not because I
was scared I didn't care that these guys
were going to crush me I freaked them
but I didn't want to betray his
friendship I didn't want to lose his you
know believing in me and his trust so I
didn't say anything
but you know back back in the early 80s
sexual assault wasn't really a thing
like it wasn't I guess in the public eye
so I didn't really know like I kind of
knew what happened but I was having a
hard time processing it
and now I just look back and I go man I
wish I would have done something but you
know forward of that event
um you know I took it upon myself to
defend the weak and the innocent and you
know I took a couple of ass kickings and
in between but
you know uh didn't matter I stopped I
stopped the bullying and that's all that
mattered and I guess that's partially
why I was I was gravitating toward the
life of civil service and military
service you know I was in the reserves
for eight years Army Reserve and uh
because I liked I liked to be a
protector I like to help
you know it wasn't like this
some people say oh that you know certain
guys with a messiah complex or this it
wasn't that it was just this
sense of benevolence that was put into
my soul by my watching my dad watching
his example
he didn't even want me to be a fireman
because he knew it was dangerous and he
got sick from it
and when he realized how much I wanted
it then he then he told me go and re you
know study go be a boss
um so
I I thoroughly took uh satisfaction out
of out of being a protector you know the
fact that people called us at their
worst moment
um and trusted us to fix it you know
when I was a police officer it was a
little different and I don't really know
how any of those response police
officers now do that job today even back
in the late 80s it was brutal I remember
I got assigned to Alphabet City which is
East 2nd through 14th Avenue A through D
down in lower Manhattan and at the time
it was overrun with crack the height of
the crack Wars
New York City had 2 500 homicides a year
most of it related to crack and uh I got
dropped off by a city bus as a newly
minted police officer on a five degree
night
four nights before Christmas because I
graduated the academy
on the 20th and on the 21st I was
walking the beat in this neighborhood
and we walked we each had our own block
by ourselves and I'm going holy crap I'm
20 years old I'm I'm sitting duck out
here I was scared to death and they
would literally drop bathtubs and toilet
bowls
and huge pieces of wood and whatever off
the roofs of the burned out tenements to
keep us off the block so they could deal
so they could deal their drugs
so one night I think I had a week on the
street and they could see you got a
brand new uniform you had a shield with
no Awards over it they know the the as
we call them the scales the the
criminals they they knew right away
so they're going to see what you have
and I had a guy who robbed the store
with a with a fake shotgun there was a
couple pipes wrapped up in tape and he
went in and took the money and I see him
I I got the call someone must have saw
it called it and he's 100 yards away and
I go sprinting down the street and I was
much leaner guy back then I was a
sprinter in high school also
and he sees me and as he goes to turn
around I'm like oh my god do I shoot him
do I what do I do and lucky for me he
tossed the the faux shotgun underneath
the car so now I lunge and I grab him
and I didn't even have a chance to call
back up I was by myself so I get a
handcuff on him and I'm trying to twist
them back so I can get the second cuff
on but he's fighting me and he's
spinning and he's trying to punch me so
luckily with my other hand I got off on
my radio and in New York City signal
1013 means send everybody send the
Cavalry this is really bad and Signal
1085 is kind of when you need some help
but you don't want everybody coming
because you're a little embarrassed that
you need the help so I just said you
know narcotics post 82 uh you know can I
get a unit on an 85
and this older cop heard the fear the
trepidation of my voice and he just came
flying down the street
and uh pulled up in the car told
dispatch Central no further no further
which means we're here we've got this
don't don't have people racing in to get
hurt
and he just calmly comes out the car
he's an old legendary guy Donnie and
he grabs the guy and he just boom boom
hits him in her face twice and this guy
goes down takes his handcuffs out cuffs
him takes mine off hands me my cuffs
lifts the guy up he says son where you
from
I said son from Staten Island he goes
yeah me too this ain't F in Staten
Island this is effing Alphabet City and
he goes you see that corner over there
and there's a monument there's a there's
a street sign and there was two officers
that were his best friends Rocco Laurie
and John Foster one white officer one
African-American officer sitting in a
patrol car together they're assassinated
in the early 70s he says you know who
those guys are I said yes sir we used to
there's there's a school named after
room in Staten Island I said we used to
play against him in basketball he goes
yeah those are my best friends he goes
he takes the guy
boom hits him again he says you see what
you're wearing you're the law you see
this this is a mutt a mutt you do not
reason with you understand me hits him
again throws them in a patrol car he
said welcome to Alphabet City son get
tough or get dead don't worry I'll bring
him in I'll clear it with the sergeant
because the guy now is beating you know
bleeding
and I stood there horrified and I went
holy crap
if the fire department doesn't call me I
got to do this for 20 years before I can
get a base pension
I don't think I'm going to make 20 days
and you know it got a little better I
mean you get better at it you you have
guys like Don who you know he's passed
now but like
you know he was there in the 60s and the
70s when it was riots and just calm as
cool as a cucumber just doing the job
and you had guys like him that wanted
you to do well wanted you to inspire you
to do better
and you know one of my like I guess I
don't know
Things I Hate About Society now is
everybody's an influencer right
everybody's a content creator and an
influencer well an influencer is
somebody that wants you to buy something
buy the crap that they're selling wear
the crap that they're selling wear the
perfume or the cologne or what the hat
that they're only there for Commerce
right
I like inspires
I still hope I can be that to my kids
and other kids or young people that are
willing to listen
but
influencers are just you know they're
robbing people of their their own minds
right these young people are so hooked
up on uh I don't have my phone right now
but that that device right you know my
father my father used to call it the TV
the idiot box and he'd say get away from
the idiot box and read a book or you're
going to ruin your mind
and to me I don't really say it but I
look at the phone and I'm guilty of it I
I needed to get here for my train ticket
for you know you can't function without
it
but the phone is ruling people's lives
and they're almost like zombies on the
phone and I call it a zombie box
sometimes to myself I'm like look at
these people they're walking in front of
you I had a guy the other damn riding a
bicycle he's coming right at me one hand
he's reading his phone I go right he
just goes right he wasn't doing it on
purpose he just wasn't paying attention
I go left he goes left and I'm just
about to collide into this guy and I
stop and he throws me an attitude like
I'm and I wanted and I I just wasn't
even worth saying it but I'm like dude
you just almost got into a collision
what if I was a car because everybody's
zombified by this box they need
validation from the phone from social
media how many likes how many hits how
many would I I'm not even on social
media so I can't even tell you what what
it is but it's it's almost sad in a way
because people have become powerless to
the media you know I I'm unfortunately a
bit of a News Junkie um so I I check in
on the news sites you know multiple
times a day and it's a bad habit because
it's all toxic
and sometimes I'll read the comments
about the stories
and the comments are vicious you know
someone drowns and then you get some
idiot well he should have learned how to
swim or or they'll try to make some sort
of snarky tongue-in-cheek joke about a
12 year old drowning or you know like
what the hell's wrong with you and it's
so toxic but what happens is
these young people buy into it right
it's like if if they're not socially
popular
their life's over you know my my high
school my alma mater it was this
beautiful young girl who
someone started a rumor that she slept
with the whole football team
and
an hour later she jumped in front of the
commuter train on Staten Island and took
her own life because
it wasn't true she didn't sleep the
whole football team she was just dating
one of the guys but some vicious jealous
people because she was very attractive
very intelligent decided that they were
going to crush her
socially right emotional terrorists they
I don't like you so I'm gonna I'm gonna
end you I'm gonna Crush you cancel you
and this poor little soul
took her own life because she would
rather die than
not be popular or or I shouldn't say it
that way she the pain that it caused her
by that vicious rumor she just couldn't
get past that
and it broke my heart I actually went to
that train station one day
and I prayed for her I stopped where she
is months later but it bothered me so
much as a father and and I literally sat
at the train station and prayed
and I said God just please let this
little angel be with you because
she didn't deserve that you know
um and I just feel that this whole this
whole social media thing and and
politicians and and the media business
are guilty of it they are on a mission
to have us divided into perpetuity they
want us to hate each other be envious be
jealous you know
um they want everyone to believe that if
you're a different color or different
religion or different sex or you know
Identity or whatever that you can't get
along
you know one of my dearest friends he
was one of my men uh when I worked in
Manhattan
Fitzroy Haynes JR this gentle beautiful
soul
his parents were Jamaican immigrants his
dad came here to join the United States
Marines and Fitzy followed his dad
and 50 then finished up the Marines and
joined the fire department and on his
very first shift
in FDNY
he was night into day of 9 11. I'm one
of the senior firefighters when the call
came in at about a quarter to nine
shift doesn't end till nine he threw
Fitzy off he said you're not going I got
this and Tommy Kelly went on that truck
and Tommy Kelly died and Fitzy didn't
graffiti went there and Doug and Doug
and Doug and
breathed in toxins for God knows how
long the nine months it took us to clear
up
and uh
2010 Christmas 2010 he died of a heart
attack 40 years old
and
he was African-American and I was white
and I loved him like he was my brother
but the the evil forces within the media
and the press and social media whatever
they would lead you to believe that
there was no way possible that I could
love Fitzroy Haynes that he could be my
friend my brother
and that pisses me off because people
are getting fed such lies on a daily
basis about stuff like that and and it's
just so sad because why why would why
would these forces do that why were the
media and the politicians
just want this
eternal divide
because of money
and because of power
and that's it
and sadly enough we're all buying into
most of us are buying into it you know
uh
so you became a fireman
uh what year
how old were you I I swore Into the Fire
Department
on October 21st 1990
and I was uh I just turned 22 years old
and uh you know on the happiest days of
my life I
I uh how long do you have to wait before
I took the test in 1987. well you were
caught for how long I was caught for
about 17 months not even two years it
was quick uh but I took the test 77
000 people took the test in 1987. and
they were going to hire about 2500
guys and girls came from around the
nation because you know FDNY
you know uh what kind of brash New
Yorkers right we we think we're the best
at everything and you know what like our
Yankees or Mets or football Giants well
they're in New Jersey but
uh working on FDNY is like playing for
the Yankees you know when I was a little
kid playing baseball on Staten Island
man if you get to the Yankees
you made it
and uh that's how I felt getting on the
job but now unfortunately there's people
that are suing because they didn't get a
fair chance at a test and that their
school wasn't good enough and this and
that they're suing to get on the
department
they're getting the job they're getting
back pay in a settlement and they're
refusing to go in to a fire
because they didn't realize what they
signed up for you know uh
you know no disrespect to say sanitation
workers
very defined job go clean up the city
pick up the trash fire department
respond to some dangerous crap you know
you saw that crane accident yesterday
right in Manhattan I mean that's that's
that's just on a daily basis in this
city
they don't really pay you much money
um
it's better nowadays than it was I came
on a job as a cop where you're making
12.50 an hour
and if you made 11.50 an hour you were
entitled to Public public benefits
so I was risking my life for a dollar
more an hour and then someone's sitting
at home doing nothing
and now these people that are suing for
this job yeah it's a great job it's got
great benefits it's a great schedule
work 24 hours you're off 48 but a lot of
times you come home you're exhausted you
you just spent 24 hours running around
and I won't lie to Some Nights it's
quiet don't do a lot but other nights
never come back so shortly after you
started that 9 11 happened yeah no I had
11 years
um
I went to the first bombing in 1993.
and uh that was a real Awakening for me
because at the time I worked in Atlanta
company 105.
and uh
one of the men who molded me was
Lieutenant William mudry
and he was tough he's a tough guy
and uh I fractured my back three years
in and uh
I left his command to go out to a
quieter place for a while to heal up
because I was pretty hurt and he he was
angry at me but we
we forgave Each Other Well he forgave me
um but he taught me the job
and uh
I wrote him a letter when I got promoted
to Lieutenant thanking him and I saw him
thank me for the letter
and on his last night on the job I ran
in with him on the fire he was in a
different company at the time in
overtime
and I gave me a big hug
and Bill wasn't the type of guy I tell
you I love you
and he said uh
I'm proud of you kid
you came out good I trained you right
and you put it to work
just never forget it's all about your
men and their safety everything else is
just
and I said thanks boss I said
get a lot of fishing and enjoy yourself
and uh
that was a 2008 and I lost touch with
him because Bill wasn't a phone call
text kind of guy so
about two years ago I
decided I need to find them I need to
thank him personally he doesn't know
that I got sick and I had to retire and
I just want to let him know hey I wish I
could have done my 35 years like I
planned
I actually would have had 35 years last
week that was I'm sorry 34. so one more
year my plan was 35 and out
and I just want to let them know it got
cut short but you know
you still trained me right and I never
forgot what he said protect your men
Train Your Man
one of my best buddies Hugh who's uh
tired for him in cancer a couple times
now veterinarian smart guy
he was in Sloan two years ago getting
cancer surgery and his nurse was fireman
from 105.
so he puts me on the phone and he says
hey bro I understand you used to work on
105 I said yeah yeah I said How's my
mentor William Audrey
that was a long pause
and he said I'm sorry to tell you this
bro
and when someone does that nowadays it's
gone died from 9 11. well Bill's lungs
were compromised pretty badly
33 years on the job busy busy trucks and
911. and he's come to
covert that was healthy as a horse and
he got a bunch of fishing in down in
Florida like you wanted
but he died 71 years old
and he should have lived way longer than
that
and I never got that chance to thank him
but I was with him
1993 at the bombing
and the senior firefighter driving a
truck Henry Miller
and tradition in the FDNY as a senior
man looks out for you he trains you
he chastises you opponent not someone
punishes you but when you f up they let
you know
but they're there
to guide you teach you inspire you
so I was with Hank that day and I was
under his wing as his you know Junior
man he's the senior man I'm sticking to
his side with the lieutenant
we go to the first bombing a couple
hours after as an extra company to help
out and uh
Hank looks around and he just said you
know
they didn't do it right kid
he says uh they blew it off in the
middle here and he goes if they did it
in the corner you got a supporting
column he says they would have dropped
this building in Canal Street
and he said mark my word they'll come
back and they'll do it right and it'll
be in your lifetime in your career
and the cruel irony was on the morning 9
11.
Hank was driving 105.
and one of my lieutenants who taught me
the job
a lot about being a man
about being a dad
his his probie as we call our rookies
probe son was on a truck with Hank 105.
and Dennis Jr died with Hank that
morning
Hank saw it right he prophesied that he
knew it
he knew these evil bastards would not
give up without taking those buildings
now
and he was one of the first guys I
thought of when I got in there I was I
was off duty
driving the Moonlight Staten Island oil
truck and uh raced in
got to my firehouse going 14 at the time
they were there Dennis senior was
working
in charge of the crew for the day from
114 knowing his son was responding as he
was responding
and my childhood best friend John short
one block on Avenue down in engine 201
spawning in
and I'm racing in off duty
get to the Firehouse according to the
command to the Battalion and they said
get a city bus get as many guys who sign
in and get down there
guys come racing in from home
side jobs whatever they were doing
we get whatever gear we could get we
stopped a city bus in the street we
Commander it never forget the guy John
he says I'm sorry I can't give you the
boss I'll drive you
I said do you understand you're going
into a war zone he says I can't give you
my boss I know you have to get there
he drove us
and as we came over to Brooklyn Bridge
First Tower was already down
and we heard 114. go on scene signal
1084. 14's nickname is tally ho
from an old Airborne Ranger Jack Carroll
who came back from
World War II jumped Normandy
and when they used to jump out the
planes they yell tally ho
so when we first got radios
Jack refused to say 10-4 so when they
asked for they'd send you on a dispatch
call on the radio you're supposed to
follow up with 10-4 you'd say 114 tally
ho hang up the radio if dispatchers
would get pissed he just kept doing it
and then it stuck
and now all these years later out of 350
engines and ladders it's the only
Fire Company in New York City that
sometimes get called by their nickname
and not their numerical designation
so Dennis put them on scene tally ho
with 1084.
church and church investor or west
investee
checking into the command post
and all of a sudden now
30 40 minutes later we're coming over
that bridge
second tower was down right in front of
us
and I just said All My Friends Are Dead
and I didn't get there on time